The idea about having a coat of many
colors would be that the person who is the
appropriate leader because we met,
or the proper person,
which would be the same thing.
One of the things that these old stories
are trying to express and to figure out
is how is it that you should act,
which is the same as what
constitutes the ideal.
Those are the same questions and the
hand here with Joseph is while you should
wear a coat of many colors,
which means that you should be able to
go have a drink in the pub with the guys
who were,
you know,
dry walling year your house and you
should be able to have a sophisticated
conversation with someone who's more
educated in an abstract way and that maybe
you should be equally
comfortable in both situations,
right?
Because you might think,
well there's more.
One of the indications that there's
more to you is that you can be put more
places and function properly.
And that would be a good thing to aim at.
Because
here's the other issue is that you know
perfectly well that the fundamental
tragedies of life and your exposure to
malevolence in the course of that life.
So those being the worst things,
there's not a lot you can do to alter
that fundamentally because their
conditions of existence,
you're going to be subject
to your vulnerability and
your going to be subject to
malevolence.
That's that.
And you can't hide from it cause
it actually makes it worse.
So you're stuck with it.
So then the question is,
well,
what are your options?
And one option is to curse the structure
of being for being malevolent and
tragic and fair enough.
And now there is to make yourself so
damn differentiated and Dynamic and Abel
that you're more than a match for that.
Now that's not an easy thing,
but it doesn't matter because
what's the alternative?
There's no good alternative.
And that's also worth knowing.